Merry Christmas, Clara.
Godfather!
Your gift this year will be something you'll never forget.
Most people don't realize there are troubled realms within our world
and you hold the key to their secrets.
Remember, Clara. Nothing is as it seems.
Where am I?
You're in the Four Realms, Princess Clara
Princess?
At your service, your majesty.
Maybe I have been spending too much time in the attic.
Welcome to our world!
The land of snowflakes,
The land of flowers,
And the land of sweets!
But in the fourth realm,
This is where our troubles began.
Mother ginger started this war.
Don't you know it's dangerous here?
I hope you'll be the one to finish it.
It's time to save the kingdom
It's just the laws of physics
Do those laws always work?
As far as I know
Ready? Go!
She's gathering her forces.
You're the only one who can stop her
[Yelp] Hang on!
I've been expecting you
It's time
You